one of the beautiful things about
business in life is that when you solve
problems you create more problems if
you're broke being broke sucks when you
have money taxes also suck they're both
problems if you solve your poverty
problem and you start making lots of
income you then have a tax problem now
you may prefer those problems but they
are problems nonetheless what we want to
do is always know what the Journey of
the customer is going to be ahead of
them and we should because we're the
ones who've done this 100 times and so
we should know what next problem is
going to come up and if we put our
thinking caps on we say hey well if
there's six steps to this problem why
don't I solve the first two and then
they're going to ENC or problem three
and then I make that my paid thing now I
completely solve problem one and problem
two but it naturally leads the S to
problem three which I can then charge
for